Grand Theft Auto bioshock Madden these
popular franchises and more help to the
video game industry taken over 20
billion in revenues in 2013 and as the
industry continues to expand into tablet
and mobile devices that number is
expected to climb the promise of
consistent multi-billion dollar profits
makes gaming and attractive industry in
many states are an attacks arms race to
lure companies within their borders
Texas is leading the way in this
approach and is aggressively targeting
gaming companies with sweetheart tax
deals under the Texas moving image
industry incentive program the Lone Star
State has set aside 95 million over the
next two years toward grants for
developers making it the largest
incentive program in the nation and so
far it seems to be working Texas is now
only second to California when it comes
to video game employment but do the
economic benefits created by these
programs justify their costs or programs
like Texas's merely a form of corporate
welfare tax law professor Calvin Johnson
thinks the gaming industry is getting
too much bang for the buck and wants the
subsidies to stop reason caught up with
the former Treasury Department official
in his office at the University of Texas
in Austin I am primarily a tax lawyer
and I got into the video games looking
at the effective federal income tax on
games like Grand Theft Auto 5 and doom 3
and I am quoted as saying at least on
one model that the video games are the
most heavily subsidized industry in
America I don't think they've made the
case why we should double the after tax
rate of return tax ordinarily reduces
your return by a third and this is an
industry which instead of paying a tax
on a third of their profits doubles
their profits that is weird if you're
going to double the rate of return
through federal subsidies then you
really ought to have pretty good
justification that the public is getting
a benefit equal to equal to that
incredibly intense intense incentives
and I must admit I'm not convinced that
the unemployed sons spending 17 hours in
the bay
smit of his mother's house working on
his grand theft auto 5 is making a grand
contribution but tax incentives are
making a grand contribution to gamers
bottom line and it's all thanks in part
to the nature of the video game industry
which extends across the realms of
software development entertainment and
online retail making it possible to
combine tax breaks in ways other
entertainment businesses cannot years
before the first video game was even
released Congress rewrote the tax code
to allow companies to deduct all
lab-based research and development in
1969 this was expanded to allow
organizations to deduct the cost of
software development another research
and design credit was added in 1981
after fears that Japan's dominance in
the auto industry would lead to a
technological decline in the United
States these federal breaks in addition
to state incentives have been a major
boon for the gaming industry even when
they're conducting research so it has
little value outside of existing games
the old expression was throwing bales of
money out of the helicopter and that's
largely what these things are there is
no application of any human intelligence
as to no necessity and the slightest bit
that there has to be general proved
nobody there bargaining in the stingy
hard-hearted way of I will pay for this
because it's worth it don't get me wrong
if gamers are willing to pay for it
that's the free market but there isn't
any reason why we should double the rate
of return for those gamers because then
we start producing games that people
don't really want that much we're
wasting stuff because things through
twice as cheap as they ought to be twice
as profitable as they thought of me the
market ought to decide these things
while Johnson maintains that gaming
subsidies do more harm than good
supporters of the program say that
incentives are necessary to keep America
competitive in the global economy
without these incentives they argue we
could see gaming jobs outsourced to
nations with friendlier corporate tax
rates but several studies have called
into question the effectiveness of these
programs a 2013 analysis done by the Tax
Foundation found that film tax
incentives only generated 30 cents in
tax
for every dollar spent the government
shouldn't be the one who determines
winners and losers it should be the real
demand of people who really want this
stuff and while Texas is spending more
on gaming incentives more states like
Kansas Missouri and Connecticut are
scaling back or eliminating their
programs altogether perhaps legislators
are learning that states benefit when
they have a tax policy that is welcoming
to all industries instead of subsidizing
some businesses at the expense of others
you